Joining us from our Los Angeles studio,
we have been waiting for her to grace us with her presence.
Please welcome, the incredible Kathryn Hahn.
(audience cheers)
(Kathryn laughs)
Hi.
(all applauding)
Oh, my gosh.
You get better with every year of your life.
Oh, my.
It's true and we both
have been at this for a very long time.
And what do you attribute the Hahn-essence to?
(Kathryn laughs)
I mean, I don't know.
Drew, this business is so weird,
like I had no, you know, I've just been lucky, you know,
I feel like I've just been kind of one foot
in front of the other and you have no idea
what's gonna be on the other side of whatever,
and you never can hold on to anything too tightly.
And so I'm just kind of enjoying this second
and I don't have social media so that kind of,
it's all kind of feels weird anyway,
but it's been a blast and the fans are so sweet.
So it's been a really, like really tender, tender time.
Can I ask why you don't go on social media?
Why you have abstained?
Abstained.
It started, to be totally honest, out of just sheer laziness
and just not knowing how to figure it out.
I have a file of facts.
Right.
So that's who we're dealing with,
but then there's a whole lot of, I've got teenagers.
I just think there's a whole lot of like
stuff that I think I, myself, as a human
feel good separating myself from.
You have teenagers.
Yeah.
And what is their life on social media like-
So they have like, definitely, limits
on their social media, of course.
And it's very all private and it's all like,
you know, they had to write contracts.
I mean, we wrote contracts that they had to sign
like that this phone is ours.
You're allowed, like, you're borrowing it,
like we're allowed to look at anything
that you put on this and any time.
(audience laughs)
So they both been like
pretty, pretty, okay so far with like the kind of on so far.
I mean, so far it's all moving so freaking fast.
I know and this is why
I wanted to pick your brain about it
because I allow my kids on social media
and they're younger, they're seven and nine,
but I really want to keep them kids.
And I don't meet, it's really refreshing for me
to talk to another parent who like
makes contracts with their kids and wants to protect them.
I love this.
Well, I mean, I think a lot of it for me
is 'cause I'm just from Ohio.
And so there's just like a, there's like this thing for me,
it's like, this is like what it is,
like we didn't have like, you know,
I went and played outside,
like for me, it was just all about my imagination.
So like I would come home from school,
I wouldn't see my parents until it was dinner
and then I would just go back to playing and like,
I want them to have that same experience
and that didn't involve phones for me.
Well, you came from Ohio and had your play and imagination
and wanted to have them
have old world values the way you did.
I came from Hollywood and was like, I had night clubs
and we had completely different experiences
and yet I think our parenting.
Yes.
Really meets at a very similar place.
Yeah, I love it.
It's so interesting.
Well, something sparked with your daughter
and led her to baking, is this true?
Yes, no, she is an legit incredible baker,
and she's very passionate about baking and about animal,
she's a real animal advocate.
So she has like a password protected website
where you can buy, you know, baked goods
and all the proceeds, she says on a disclaimer,
"All proceeds from your purchases will go
to the Kitty Bungalow Animal Shelter," which is like,
I don't think she knows what disclaimer means exactly, but.
(audience applauds)
Okay, so there is proof right there that you have done
something really amazing with your parenting,
if your kid is doing animal philanthropy.
Yeah.
And doing bake sales
for animals, congratulations.
What a relief.
Sure.
Do you know, was there like a connector,
like a light bulb, like an aha moment
or was she born like Dr. Doolittle?
She's like Dr. Doo,
like I'm telling you every Saturday night,
either my husband or I are spending our time
volunteering at a cat shelter.
That's my Saturday night, Drew.
I love it.
Because she's a minor.
(audience applauds)
I do.
I love that.
I could use a Saturday night, one of these days,
but it means so much to her.
I think we have a vet in our future.
I have to ask about the "Agatha: House of Harkness" show
that is the spinoff from "WandaVision".
This is going to be so huge.
Is there anything that you can tell us,
even though I'm sure you have a Marvel muzzle.
Yeah.
What can we know?
I mean,
I didn't even know the title of the show
until it was released to the public
like they keep it so tight.
Is there a possibility that Mephisto
might be making some type of appearance?
I keep hearing that.
I have no idea.
That was like a big thing during "WandaVision",
but I have no, who knows.
I mean, I think right now, like anything, like Marvel,
I mean, who knows it's anything is probably possible,
but like, I have never heard anything definitive
about that at all.
If you could pass anyone as Mephisto,
who would you pick if you are in the driver's seat
and, you know, Agatha gets to pick her Mephisto,
would there ever be anyone who fits the bill?
(Drew and the audience laugh)
I mean, I'll say,
in terms of a real great deflection of that question
(Drew laughs loudly)
is that there is something that does feel so badass
to be playing like, you know, we think of a witch
and you think of, you know, immediately you think of a woman
who is loud, who is mysterious,
who is dangerous because she's complicated
and she's misunderstood.
And all that stuff is a real turn on to me
as a performer in terms of digging
into this person a little bit more, very excited.
Well, everyone will be hanging on every detail
that comes up.
Me, too.
Manifestos out of this.
Nice.
The shrink next door, Casey Wilson, came on the show
and I actually did her makeup.
I'm so in love with her.
I was like (indistinct).
Oh.
Her the whole time.
Isn't she the dearest, softest, sweetest, kindest?
I love her.
I loved her in the show and I love this show
and I love that your character
encourages your brother, Will Ferrell,
to seek a shrink.
Yeah.
And then.
No.
Yeah, no good deed goes unpunished.
(audience laughs)
I think Paul Rudd.
I know.
Is so...
This is one of my favorite things I've ever seen him in.
He is different in this show.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, he's so good.
There's the facial expressions,
this Jewish therapist that he plays.
Yes.
Like the mensch-type
of seemingly person that he is in the beginning
and how it all grows.
I've never seen Paul Rudd in this form.
His body language is different.
Yeah.
His smile.
He is so good.
(upbeat music)